[Music]
thank you
too important although not major
characters within Philip K Dick's novel
The Man In The Heist Castle are a young
Japanese couple the kasurus Betty and
Paul and were introduced to them in the
very first chapter of the work and all
of the interactions that we see with
them in the work are through Robert
children they enter his shop where
they're interested in checking out his
American
artifacts and they'll eventually invite
him to dinner and then Paul will have a
very interesting and revealing
conversation with Robert childon about
the jewelry that he's selling from the
Ed Frank jewelry company which
represents something new and as opposed
to quite a few of the other characters
like to go me or Frank and Julianna
Frank and of course Robert children we
we don't get their inner thoughts that's
not something that dick provides us with
and so we're seeing them in significant
part with Through The Eyes of Robert
children and in terms of what it is that
they say that reveals their points of
view so let's take a look at the very
first interactions in chapter one
so we we find that after his interaction
with tagumi then children says he became
aware of someone a couple had entered
the store young man and a girl both
handsome well-dressed ideal he calmed
himself and moved professionally easily
in their Direction smiling they were
bending to scrutinize a counter display
had picked up a lovely ashtray married
he guessed live out in city of the
winding Mist the new exclusive
apartments on Skyline overlooking
Belmont and he greets them and the young
man says really excellent pieces sir and
children bow spontaneously now here's a
really interesting description their
eyes warm not only with human Bond but
the shared enjoyment of the art objects
he sold their Mutual tastes and
satisfactions remained fixed upon them
they were thanking him for having things
like this for them to see pick up and
exam and handle perhaps without even
buying yes they thought they know what
sort of store they are in This Is Not
Tourist trash and then he thinks oh I
could fall in love with this girl and
they have some discussion he says are
your earrings purchased here and she
says no at home and Sheldon says to
himself no Contemporary American art
only the past could be represented here
and then he asked them are you here for
long in our San Francisco
and the man says I'm stationed here
indefinitely with standard of living for
unfortunate areas Planning Commission of
inquiry Pride showed on his face not the
military not one of the gum chewing
boorish draftees with their greeting
peasant faces wandering up Market Street
gaping at the body shows the sex movies
the shooting galleries the cheap
nightclubs etc etc he says no this man
was of the elite cultured educated even
more so than Mr tagumi who after all was
a high official with the ranking trade
mission on the Pacific coast to go me
was an old man his attitudes had formed
in the war cabinet days and this is
going to be very important these are
younger people they represent a
different attitude a different mindset
and so they talk a bit about
um you know what sort of artifacts are
available uh the the girl says we're
starting to decorate a bit undecided do
you think you could inform us and
children says well I could arrange to
arrive at your apartment bringing
several hand cases I can suggest in
context at your leisure and they go back
and forth and children eventually says
shall we make arrangements and he takes
down their name and address and he
examines his notes and he thinks about
yes these These are younger people he
says it was a chance to meet a young
Japanese couple socially on a basis of
acceptance of him as a man rather than
as a yank or at best a Tradesman Who
Sold art objects these new young people
of the rising generation who did not
remember the days before the war or even
the war itself they were the hope of the
world Place difference did not have the
significance for them it will end
children thought someday the very idea
of place not governing governed and
governing but people but yet he's
trembling with fear as well so this is a
very interesting engagement isn't it and
you know they look at him with kindness
not superiority there's the possibility
of some sort of equality between them
despite the power differential the race
difference all of that and then they
invite him to their home and not just as
a business proposal but for dinner a
social engagement
this is very important
he says to himself I'm not invited into
business context but as a dinner guest
and there's going to be a lot of
ambivalence on the part of Robert
childen in his engagement but he's
treated as an honored guest uh you know
Betty meets him there Mr Children Enter
he enters tasteful in the extreme and so
ascetic a few pieces of lamp here table
bookcase print on the wall and we'll
talk about what this signifies in a bit
and then Mr kasura says a drink Scotch
and Soda and he says Mr kasura and then
Mr casura says Paul the young Japanese
man said indicating his wife Betty and
you are
Mr Children murmured Robert what are
they doing there they're establishing a
certain kind of equality they're
engaging in uh exchange of first names
saying that our races don't matter so
much uh all the things that that people
pay attention to outside that's not it
and they engage in a whole series of
conversations which again
some ambiguity
involved in these and uh coming back to
the description
all of the the description of their home
uh
the incredible Japanese sense of Wabi it
could not be thought in English the
ability to find in simple objects of
Beauty Beyond that of the elaborate or
the ornate something to do with the
arrangement now this is children
thinking to himself about this young
couple and then we go on a little bit uh
further and we see another description
here this the Wabi around him radiations
of Harmony that's it he decided the
proportion balance they meaning the
kasuras are close to the Dao these two
young Japanese that's why I reacted to
them before I sense the Dao through them
saw a glimpse of it myself and then he
sort of Muses what would it be like to
really know the Dao the Dao is that
which first lets the light then the dark
occasions the interplay of the two
Primal forces so there's always renewal
it is that which keeps it all from
wearing down the universe will never be
extinguished because just when the
darkness seems to have smothered it all
to be truly Transcendent the new seeds
of light are reborn in the very depths
that is the way and then his thoughts
are broken by Betty saying an hors
d'oeuvre here so this is really putting
them up on kind of a pedestal isn't it
now they discuss a lot of different
topics for example the succession that's
likely to happen within the Nazi party
and the uh the Reich and it's very
interesting to see the differences
between them Paul says international
news much and notice these days and um
they're talking about like who is under
arrest and who isn't
and then Paul asks you know what's going
what else is reported by the napon times
and she says much confusion and
intriguing Army units moving from hither
to yawn leaves canceled border stations
closed reichstagon sessions speeches by
all and then they talk about Googles and
children are saying oh it's such a great
order you know a A1 Nazi speaker and and
Paul and Betty say yeah that's quite
true and then they start talking about
um
sexual depravity on the part of the
Nazis and
um you know children says I wouldn't
give rumors the time of day Paul says
well I was thinking more of guring he
seems to be engaging in orgies and stuff
like that and children says lies and
then Betty keeps the Peace by saying ah
the subject isn't worth discussing and
then Paul says something
lots of hot blood stirred up in
political discussion everywhere you go
essential to keep head and he also says
maybe we should drop politics right
they're going to come back to it though
and then they begin to discuss some
literature turns out that Paul himself
as he's going to tell us is very
interested in science fiction he
describes himself as an Enthusiast he
began that hobby early in his life he
was merely 12 during the early years of
the war and they begin discussing this
absolutely Central book The Grasshopper
lies heavy an alternate history book
within this alternate history novel and
they get children's interest intrigued
in part because in it the Allies win the
war but there's a worry about you know
what does it mean that the
Russians were in the allies did they win
the war and Robert is actually going to
go on kind of a rant about how you know
the Japanese and the Germans winning the
war even though it's subjugated America
was worth it
precisely because it meant that the
Communist hordes could be kept at Bay he
says we had to suffer to pay the cost to
stop Slavic world inundation and then
Betty says something really interesting
this is where she reveals her own
mindset and probably that of Paul She
says personally I do not believe any
hysterical talk of World inundation by
any people Slavic or Chinese or Japanese
she regarded Robert placidly she was in
complete control of herself not carried
away but she intended to express her
feeling
so this is quite revelatory these people
are rather free of the
nationalistic
mindset of others they begin to discuss
music and Paul as it turns out is an
Enthusiast not just of Science Fiction
but of negro music which he says is the
really authentic American music right
and he brings up Bonk Johnson kid URI
and the like early Dixieland Jazz and
Robert Sheldon says no I'm not
interested in that stuff I prefer
classical Bach and Beethoven and he
feels a bit of resentment towards Paul
was he supposed to deny the great
masters of European music in favor of
New Orleans Jazz from The Honky Tonks
and bistros of the Negro quarter and
Paula Paul actually says you know maybe
I'll play some of this for you and
Betty's like nah don't do that yeah so
there's an interesting thing going on
there and they also talk briefly about
the cuisine what does Betty make T-bone
steak baked potato with sour cream and
chives trying to make it as authentic
and American experience as possible and
children really appreciates that because
he he doesn't have steak very often and
he's like oh thank God I don't have to
have Japanese food like I do pretty much
all the time so there's some interesting
stuff going on there what else is
happening in all these engagements we
see children doing two things one is at
several different points he expresses
himself in a way that is disharmonious
and he's like oh man I'm blowing it here
you know and there's several different
places where he's like ah these these
Japanese they're so cultured I really am
kind of a barbarian in relation to them
but then and this is a sign of
children's own character
he also on his own is sort of putting
them down in his own head
and he uh says I'm trying to pretend
that these Japanese people and I are
alike observe even when I burst out as
to my gratification they won the war
that my nation lost there's still no
Common Ground we're not equal we're not
even really doing the same thing he goes
on and says what words mean to me is in
sharp contrast vis-a-vis them their
brains are different their souls
likewise witness them drinking from
English bone china cups eating with U.S
silver listening to negro style of music
it's all on the surface
wealth and power makes us available to
them but it's air zots
as as the day is long what is their
substitute fake right he says even the
eaching they took that from the Chinese
and then he thinks to himself you cook
the native foods to Perfection what they
say is true your powers of imitation are
immense apple pie Coca-Cola stroll after
the movie Glenn Miller you could Pace
together out of tin and rice paper a
complete artificial America rice paper
mom in the kitchen rice paper dad
reading the newspaper rice paper pup At
His Feet Paul was watching him silently
Robert children suddenly noticed
noticing the man's attention seized his
line of thought and applied himself to
his food can he read my mind he wondered
um and can he see what I'm really
thinking I know I didn't show it I kept
the proper expression so children is
kind of a conflicted character isn't it
isn't he and there's really nothing to
suggest that the uh kasuras themselves
fit the ma model of what it is that
children is thinking about them and the
Japanese in general if anything they
seem to be exceptions to this the sign
of a new direction for perhaps the elite
perhaps the youth
and
the scene which is quite long ends with
uh Robert you know leaving and thinking
to himself I always wondered what it
would be like to meet certain customers
socially not so bad after all this may
help me in my business it's therapeutic
to meet these people who have
intimidated you and to discover what
they're really like then the
intimidation goes and we can ask
ourselves did he really learn what they
were really like or not that's a great
question here finally we come to an
engagement which is not involving Betty
but just Robert Sheldon and Paul kosura
um
it does involve Betty in a way because
Robert attempted a sort of Seduction
sending by way of Paul a piece of
jewelry from Ed Frank jewelry which
represents the new the American right uh
which is supposed to be destined for
Betty and he and Paul meet up and Paul
tells him
um I didn't actually send the piece of
jewelry to her it's not left this office
and uh Paul says what I did do this is
show it to a number of business
associates individuals who share my
taste for American historic objects or
artifacts of General artistic aesthetic
Merit none of course had ever seen such
as this before as you explain no such
contemporary work has been known and I
think too you inform that you are the
sole representative and what do these
people do they laughed at it and I too
Paul says laugh behind my hand invisible
to you the other day when you appeared
and showed me this thing naturally to
protect your song Hua I concealed that
Amusement as you don't no doubt recall I
remain more or less non-committal in my
apparent reaction so he's revealing
himself to Robert he's which shows a
certain kind of Integrity on his part
and then he says
I actually realized something this piece
of jewelry
has woo
not wobby
it doesn't have aesthetic value in
itself
it's got something almost like a
religious value except it's different
than religious artifacts because this is
a work of art this is something
radically new he is going to say
um
here's how he discusses that in other
words an entire new world is pointed to
by this the name for it is neither art
for it has no form nor religion what is
it I have pondered this pin unceasingly
you cannot fathom it it is authentically
a new thing on the face of the world
what does this show us about Paul he's
willing to share this information with
Robert and he is able to grasp and
appreciate this
so Paul himself is you know quite an
extraordinary person and then he tells
you know uh Robert that I have tried to
impress my viewpoint on my colleagues
one of them has an extraordinary
business opportunity for you we can take
this jewelry if you've got some of it
and we can Mass produce it as charms
which could be sold throughout South
America poor people would love this sort
of thing you could become very very
wealthy Robert and what he's doing here
is he's
uh posing Robert with a crisis with a
challenge and at first
um
children
goes along with it and uh you know Paula
said don't
under-evaluate the possibility suggested
by the esteemed importer he's a shrewd
personage you know this could make you
incredibly wealthy and
um children says I'll follow your advice
I'll leave to visit the Importer and
then Paul doesn't seem happy with this
and he says he asks Robert will the will
the artist go along with this and
children says yes I think they will then
something in his tone made Robert
children take sudden note a nebulous
peculiar emphasis there and it swept
over children without a doubt he'd split
the ambiguity he saw the whole Affair a
cruel dismissal of American efforts
taking place before his eyes cynicism
but God forbid he'd swallowed Hook Line
and Sinker got me to agree step by step
led me along the Garden Path to this
conclusion products of American hands no
good for good for nothing but to be
models for junky good luck charms and he
says Christ we are barbarians compared
to them we're no more than boobs against
such pitiless reasoning Paul did not say
did not tell me our art was worthless he
got me to say it for him
and
he decides
I'm going to do something different here
he says to
Paul
I am humiliated
and Paul says why so Robert now notice
tones of concern but detached above
involvement Paul one moment
I am proud of this work there can be no
consideration of trashy good Lark charms
I reject
and then he says thank you however and
Paul bows and Robert childenbaud and
then he says the men who made this are
American Proud artists myself included
to suggest trashy good luck charms
therefore insults us and I ask for
apology
Paul surveyed him one eyebrow lifted
slightly and his thin lips twitched a
smile I demand children said that was
all you could carry it no further he now
merely waited nothing occurred please he
thought help me
then Paul says
this goes back to this issue of equality
and graciousness
Paul said forgive my arrogant imposition
he held out his hand all right Robert
children said they shook hands and
what's going on here is it complete
equality no not exactly but it's a
creation of equality and this can happen
precisely not just because of Robert
children sudden moment of courage and
decision but because Paul is the sort of
person who not only you know engineered
this situation but can respond
appropriately we go back to closeness to
the Dao and the proper response so we
have some very very interesting
characters in this husband-wife team of
young Japanese people cultured Elite
engaging primarily with Rob or children
but presumably with the greater world
around them and that's all that we get
to know about these two people in man in
the High Castle but it's something I
would say quite attractive quite
appealing quite admirable that we have
revealed to us